some 12 million Europeans are
potentially exposed to the fumes from
diesel engines at their place of work be
they bus drivers truckers or even
construction workers the World Health
Organization says diesel emissions can
cause cancer in humans Parliament wants
to reduce workers exposure to dangerous
substances by setting upper limits as
well as diesel fumes MEP s added seven
other chemical compounds to the list of
recognized carcinogens and mutagens
whether they're inhaled or handled like
used mineral oils lhasa civil rioseco
deprovision develop on the summit by
year audible amount of a political
solution akela Chui Lucas report on one
successful process used to give is your
pet Amano
Bhaskar yep a tree a la sortie de
Coverley the new rules will ensure
better protection for the millions of
workers in the EU and a third revision
is already underway in Europe cancer
remains the leading cause of
work-related deaths between 7 and 12
people die every hour in the EU from
cancer linked to their place of work
[Music]